you were sort of a hero to taylor
we were heroes of each other as a matter
of fact also chuckle buddies mainly uh
but uh taylor
and also um dave have made being a
fanboy cool yeah it was never full cool
before but i go hang out over at
taylor's place and he would be wearing
his police t-shirt yeah which is why i'm
here today wearing my taylor t-shirt
you became friends yeah how did that and
he became friends with all of his heroes
you know with roger taylor with lars
ulrich
um
the guys in right he was
just a fanboy
but he
rose to prominence himself as a hero
himself as a drummer
what would you say about his drumming
skills power yeah power and enthusiasm
and solidity what does it mean for you
to be here oh it is very emotional to be
here
and perhaps the most emotional
moment of this whole thing you know
because we're all staying in one big
hotel together and laughing up and you
know talking about taylor and you know
enjoying
the brief time he was with us all too
brief but the most emotional moment for
me was at check
a couple days ago here and to see young
shane hawkins on the drums
i started crying
yeah
he's got it and he's got such power
enthusiasm he's got his father's stance
musical language that was really
emotional to see young shane up there